public sénat france 24 et rfi présente
[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ici l'europe à la fin de la semaine
les 27 se sont accordés en sommet
européen sur le futur budget de l'union
européenne et sur des ambitions
climatiques rehaussé et nous avons le
plaisir de recevoir aujourd'hui la
portugaise en charge à bruxelles des
fameux fonds de cohésion qui sont censés
rééquilibrer les richesses entre les
régions d'europe
elisa ferreira bonjour merci d'être avec
nous en duplex bonjour elisa ferreira à
l'envi ont commencé par enseigner
l'économie avant de devenir ministre de
l'environnement dans le gouvernement
socialiste d'antonio bouter res vous
êtes aussi occupé du développement
régional dans les années 90 et puis
votre carrière s'est orienté vers
l'europe et plus précisément vers le
parlement européen puisque vous y avez
été élu trois fois entre 2004 et 2014
vous êtes maintenant commissaire
européenne à un moment où votre pays le
portugal va prendre la présidence de
l'union européenne pour six mois ce sera
à partir du 1er janvier
alors dis là c'est le tweet à victorieux
du président du conseil européen à
propos du déblocage très attendu du plan
de relance et du budget à long terme de
l'union
la pologne et la hongrie ont finalement
levé leur veto est ce que cela veut dire
qu'ils acceptent désormais que
l'allocation des fonds européens soient
subordonnées au bon respect de l'état de
droit
merci merci de votre intérêt et oui
c'est un moment
exceptionnel de la vie de l'union
européenne c'est le rattrapage de
développement de
dans futur un futur qu'on ne veut pas en
sortant d'une pandémie qui a causé 6 de
problèmes en termes économiques et en
terme de santé publique et de pertes
pour les citoyens on veut appuyer et la
commission était très très
je crois à courageuse en a vingt avant
proposés et
il ya un lancement qui un lancement qui
ne reproduit pas le passé doit être un
lancement vers un heureusement digital
et un lancement qui touche les gens et
qui ne laisse personne en arrière pour
revenir sur les motifs du de la levée de
ce veto des polonais et des hongrois
il faut dire qu'au fond de cohésion il
représente un enjeu majeur sur le plan
économique 4% de leur pib
est ce que c'est ça qui les a fait
bouger parce qu'ils avaient peur
simplement que qu'on leur coupe les
vivres
je crois que c'est une façon de regarder
le problème mais je crois que c'est
quelque chose de plus fondamental
l'europe c'est une europe économique
mais c'est une robe de principes et de
valeurs
alors quand on décide de joindre l'union
européenne il y a des principes qui on
doit suivre
et ces principes sont des principes de
démocratie d'égalité entre les gens de
n'avoir pas la possibilité de
discriminer contre les gens sont par
exemple leur option de vie les options
en termes de gendre
ce n'est pas acceptable au niveau
européen aussi pour les blés budget
européen
il est fait avec l'école est rempli avec
les contributions des européens
alors il faut avoir une certitude totale
qu'ils qui sont distribués aux gens qui
ont besoin de ça et pas aux gens qui ont
le pouvoir pour retenir mais pour pour
leurs bénéfices individuels mais
justement la pologne et à la hongrie ils
ont encore la possibilité de saisir la
cour européenne de justice pour
contester ce mécanisme liant
l'attribution des fonds à l'état de
droit
ce qu'ils ont dit qu'ils allaient faire
d'ailleurs est ce que viktor orban elle
va réussir à échapper aux sanctions
financières avant une date très
importante pour lui les élections
législatives de 2022 où ils pourraient
perdre parce que parce que l'opposition
est unie alors c'est un c'est un sujet
qui est dans le cadre des règles et des
aussi l'union européenne suit doit
suivre des règles de l'état de droit et
l'état de droit veut dire qu'il y a tout
une quantité de procédures qu'on doit
respecter quand on a des suspicions des
problèmes et c'est ça qu'on fait au
niveau de la commission européenne aussi
on suit et on poursuit toutes les
les les transitions qu'on doit faire
pour appliquer l'état de l'état de droit
et c'est ça qu'on fait alors il y a
beaucoup de détails qu'on ne peut pas me
présenter dans une phase une façon
légère superficielles ça veut dire
seulement que nous sommes tous attentifs
à clé tas de droit soit respecté aussi
au niveau des institutions européennes
mais aussi au niveau des états alors
c'est un sujet qui est devenu très
visible très important elisa ferreira
dit m
des enquêtes ont été faites par l'olaf
l'office européen de lutte contre la
fraude et on sait très bien que des des
fonds ont été détournés en hongrie pour
aller vers dans la poche des proches de
viktor orban et l'union européenne
demande que ces fonds soient remboursés
ce ce qui pour l'instant n'est pas
encore le cas
44 millions d'euros de subventions est
ce que ça veut dire que les européens
passent l'épongé sur cette ardoise
non pas du tout je comme je vous ai dit
il y avait une procédure et cette
procédure se passe dans plusieurs pays
pays vous mentionnez un cas très
spécifiques et mais il y en a d'autres
et il y à tous les procédures qui sont
suivis au niveau de la commission
européenne et qui est ça inclut une
audition une confirmation des fêtes
et bien sûr il y a le remboursement si
la situation n'est pas une situation
légale et si le
l'argent a été versé sans que toutes les
procédures de transparence et de de
conformité totale avec la législation
européenne n'était pas éprouvé dès
qu'elles n'étaient pas suivis alors dans
ce cas là et il n'y a pas mal de cas
vous parler des cas un peu évident mais
il y en a d'autres
il y a toujours le remboursement de la
commission européenne pour le budget
mais pour qu'on arrive finalement à ce
stade là on doit écouter avoir la preuve
la contre-preuve et parce que c'est
aussi ça
l'état de droit alors elisa ferreira
pour illustrer ce que représentent les
fonds structurels à la fois fonds de
cohésion au fonds pour l'emploi nous
vous proposons de partir en belgique
pour un reportage auprès d'une
association belge qui a perçu 35000
euros par an depuis 2000 16 une
association de développement durable
dans l'agriculture dont notre
correspondante à l'x le bourdon a
rencontré la coordinatrice à liège
françoise vandales aimons l'écoutent
au milieu de ces salades
l'amour âge c'est une association qui a
pour mission de former des demandeurs
d'emploi en leur apprenant le métier de
maraîcher biologique et celui de
jardiniers écologique les légumes qu'on
produit ils sont destinés à la vente aux
particuliers ont fait leur récolte de
manière hebdomadaire et on va faire des
paniers de légumes donc ce sont des
assortiments de légumes bio de saison et
on va le livret chez holt à moi ces
épiceries du mot honni quel point c'est
olivier a donc ici je suis stagiaire à
la bourrache il en manque encore de
changer c'était important vraiment
d'avoir cette démarche écologique
pouvoir prendre conscience de
l'importance que ça de pouvoir produire
local et vendre locale
il faut faire avancer les choses par
rapport à tout ça et vend de la qualité
aussi
[Musique]
le projet que nous avons mis en place a
reçu je pense le soutien du fonds social
européen de par le côté vraiment
insertion d'un public très éloignées de
l'emploi
grâce au fse on a pu accueillir soixante
jeunes supplémentaires
malheureusement dans notre cas nous
avons appris que ce projet ne pourrait
pas être maintenues au-delà de 2020 ce
que j'aurais envie de dire à madame la
commissaire c'est que on est bien dans
un moment où l'europe prend des
directions très clair avec le green deal
nous on a le moyen de le faire on a
l'équipe on a la connaissance il envie
de poursuivre le projet qu'est-ce qui
pourrait être mis en place pour que ce
projet perdu et je suis ravi de voir que
vous avez trouvé et vous avez pris la
décision de montrer des projets très
positif d'insertion sociale et de
travail et d de procréer et je voudrais
en relation encore à votre dernière
question vous a ajouté que quand on a
des situations de fraude avec les fonds
structurels
on est on c'est pas admissible du tout
mais ce cas là ils sont moins de 1% en
termes statistiques en termes
quantitatifs ils sont moins d'un pour
cent
c'est à totalité des fonds congères et
on a en fait une quantité énorme de
projets alors on va en adresse ses
sujets de fraude d'une façon très très
très très
très forte très déterminés mais c'est
moins d'un pour cent et la plupart des
projets s'ils sont des projets pour les
petites et moyennes entreprises des
projets que les français connaissent
très bien
c'est le feder c'est le fondent que de
social que vous avez vous venez de
démontrer et maintenant il y aura il y à
déjà dans le terrain une possibilité qui
a été utilisé aussi par la france pour
utiliser les fonds qui étaient encore
disponibles
la présente période de programmation
pour appuyer en terme exceptionnel douce
presque tous que les états voulaient et
la france a reprogrammé traite avec
beaucoup d'intensité des fonds qui
étaient disponibles encore au niveau du
feder et du fonds social pour acheter
les masques comme tous les autres payer
des pays des ventilateurs pour appuyer
le travail à temps partiel pour appuyer
les petites et moyennes entreprises
alors pour faire tout ce qui était
considéré d'émergence et réponses et ça
va continuer avec une transition vers
une progressive normalisation avec un
vent qui s'appellerait kt et qui ajoute
aux fonds structurels que vous
connaissez bien et qu'ils vont continuer
entre 2021 et 2027
elisa ferreira le dernier sommet
européen à renforcer les ambitions
climatiques européennes ont reçu les
engagements pris il y a cinq ans puisque
au lieu d'une réduction de 40% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre par
rapport aux niveaux de 90 on est
maintenant à une ambition de 55 % de
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre à l'horizon 2030
les polonais ont bloqué
tard dans la nuit sur cette question
avant de céder c'est un pays qui marche
beaucoup au charbon ça va leur coûter
très cher de rehausser leurs ambitions
qu'est ce qu'ils ont obtenu comme
garantie pour être aidés sur ce plan
alors ils partagent je comprends que un
pays comme la pologne
quand on parle de 55 % de réduction ça
c'est pour quel pays qui dépendent comme
vous l'avez dit beaucoup de technologies
qui qui pèse beaucoup sur le sur le
climat c'est un effort très très fort et
c'est à cause ça aussi que dans les
fonds qui sont nouveaux nous avons créé
proposés et savez la législation est
déjà finie aussi il y à un fonds
spécifique pour aider les régions et je
parle des religions comme la silésie en
pologne
holder en france où la bouche sur les
bouches du rhône
il ya des régions où il y à une
concentration de démission est
atmosphérique qui sont vraiment très
très forte
et selon le niveau des pays ces pays
vont pouvoir bénéficier d'un fonds
spécifique pour aider à la transition
quand on fait un changement interne
technologique
quand on quand on a une adaptation pour
être plus en conformité avec
les objectifs d'environnement il y à des
coûts souvent des coups de caractère
social et de caractère régional parce
qu'il y à des fermetures de certaines
activités
alors il y a maintenant en fonte qui
n'est pas en fonds disponibles pour
toutes les régions mais pour ces régions
et on est en train de finaliser les
discussions avec avec la france pour
savoir si vraiment ce sont les régions
les régions
la commission a proposé à proposer et
celles sur lesquelles on va intervenir
et pour ça on a ce fonds de transition
juste alors autre grand dossier de ce
sommet et du week end d'ailleurs le
brésil on se dirige vers le pire des
scénarios vis-à-vis des britanniques
est ce que d'ailleurs le cadre
budgétaire tel qu'il vient d'être
adoptée prend en compte le coût très
élevé d'un bris exit son accord
je commence à me par répondre que aussi
les régions plus affectés par les brics
hit health rome où j'espère plus
renforcée en termes soit directe soit
des fonds structurels et ça c'est
quelque chose que les pays sont très
attentifs je suis sûr mais il ya aussi
un volet spécial de sang que milliards
d'euros qui sont maintenant nous à la
commission on travaille sur la
distribution les critères de
distribution et qui sont précisément
destinée à aider les régions qui seront
directement ou indirectement plus
affectées par la rupture des relations
traditionnelles commerciales et autres
avec avec avec le royaume uni
bien sûr qu' il y aura il n'en pacte
majeur
l'irlande ça va sans dire mais ça ne
veut pas dire de l'autre l'autre côté
qu'il n'y a pas d'autres régions qui
avaient une relation très très forte
et presque tous les pays qui avaient une
relation commerciale traditionnelle avec
l'angleterre seront seront affectés
alors c'est sûr ça on travaille ça sera
très très vite disponibles qu'elles
aient les critères selon lesquels le ses
impacts seront réduits aussi au minimum
mais ils seront là c'est vrai parce que
c'était une option du royaume uni et je
crois que si le royaume uni va s'offrir
un peu beaucoup même par cette rupture
surtout avec si la rupture n'est pas
gérer d'une façon d'une façon avec
beaucoup de soucis avec beaucoup de
détails
merci bien elisa ferreira d'avoir été
notre invité dans quelques minutes je
rejoins ma consoeur de public sénat pour
un débat hors des sentiers battus sur le
thème le coronavirus est-il un virus
révolutionnaire en tient en train de
changer radicalement nos vies à tout
pour la seconde partie de notre émission
on a beaucoup dit de mal du coronavirus
et à raison puisqu'il affecte notre
santé et nos économies mais nous voulons
aujourd'hui prendre un peu le
contre-pied et si nous regardions ce
virus comme révolutionnaire il a en
quelque sorte relancer le projet
européen il nous force à regarder en
face les conséquences du changement
climatique à réévaluer la valeur travail
changer nos modes de production et de
consommation
si à toute chose malheur est bon y at il
des leçons à tirer en positif de cette
pandémie s'est crise peut-elle
constituer un sursaut solidaire un
tournant économique et écologique nous
allons plonger nos invités dans un
effort d'introspection et de prospection
inhabituel quasi philosophique quel
monde d'après redessine l'aco vide
depuis paris corinne mayer économiste
sic analystes auteur d'un best seller
bonjour paresse qui déjà en 2004 nous
inviter à lever le pied sur le travail
auteur également darracq de à la
conquête de l'homme rouge
alors depuis bruxelles aussi au
parlement européen heidi hautala députée
européenne finlandaise des verts
ancienne ministre du développement
d'ailleurs en finlande avec un modèle
social nordique d'état providence et
d'avancer écologistes vous êtes d'avis
que le monde d'après ne doit pas trop
ressembler au monde d'avant j'imagine un
monde plus local au sens national même
c'est ce que vous souhaitez on imagine
massaly aguilar députée européenne
espagnole de vox ce parti situé à
l'extrême droite de l'échiquier
politique et qui correspond au parlement
européen au groupe
cr alors madame à ôta là on commence par
vous puisque vous êtes on le disait en
duplex du parlement européen le
coronavirus a renforcé d'un certain
point de vue l'union européenne qui a dû
s'occuper d'un nouveau domaine de
compétence la santé élevé aussi des
fonds en commun sur les marchés pour
faire face à la crise économique
le virus est en train de stimuler les
défenses immunitaires de l'union
européenne
je pense qu'il a il il est un moment de
comprendre qu' il faut mieux contrôler
le virus est ensemble et les frontières
nationales sont évoqués mais je suis sûr
que la conséquence de cette pandémie et
que l'union européenne va gagner plus de
compétences sur la question sur le
domaine de santé publique et plus de
solidarité financière la soul i will
aussi je pense que on comprend que on
est tous ici dans le marché interne et
sans frontières en principe
et si un pays souffre de quelque chose
qu'on m'aime par des miss est neuf et
sur global et il faut trouver les
solutions ensemble ça c'est la nouvelle
solidarité pour moi massaly aguilar vous
êtes eurocritique 1 mais selon un récent
sondage sur huit nations européennes
61% des personnes interrogées ont évalué
positivement les efforts des vingt-sept
face à la cohue vide et c'est une nette
progression finalement cette crise elle
a déjà réinventé le projet européen aux
yeux des citoyens qui réclament plus de
protection de l'union européenne à mon
avis l'union européenne n'a pas su gérer
cette crise mais n'essaient pas la selle
le gouvernement de mon pays n'a pas sur
le faire non plus ils n'ont pas prêté
attention ce qui se passait en chine ou
en italie ou de lui et en algérie tard
et mal à mon avis il aurait dû prendre
le commandement de répondre aux besoins
en matériel sanitaire qui était
nécessaire dès le premier moment de la
pandémie alors beaucoup d'étudiantes
l'union européenne travaille plus fort
pour bourbon pour aider tous les pays
qui sommes dans l'union européenne dont
elle habille son travail peuvent devenir
meilleurs dont vous
les plus d'union européenne massaly
aguilar au parti vox bon non écoutez je
te fendre la souveraineté nationale
l'énergie le dow jones industrial est à
mon avis si on me donnait des affaires à
la chine de plusieurs matériel médical
en espagne nous avions fait nous avions
pu mieux sortir de la crise je passe ici
vous vous connaissez que les entreprises
locales en espagne sont en ruine un mois
le gouvernement de mon pays n'a pas su
le gérer l'aide à ces entreprises
moyennes et petites qui représente les
nouveaux % des groupes d'entreprises et
les 66 de l'emploi alors il faut que on
connaît mieux la manière de ddt dll et
les entreprises petites moyennes et
surtout les aides qui bien de de
l'europe pour les différents pays et
dans sept cas pour l'espagne
alors en fait nous sommes aussi avec une
psychanalyste on le disait qu'ils
canalisent nos sociétés européennes
confrontée à une épidémie sans précédent
le virus a changé notre façon de penser
corinne meilleur d'appréhender l'avenir
selon vous le virus accentué tout l'est
les fractures de la société en fait donc
c'est un réveil face à pose toutes les
questions et qui pour certaines
n'étaient pas suffisamment posé et
notamment cette question des systèmes de
santé qui se sont montrés dans un
certain nombre de pays
insuffisant puisque des économies
drastiques avaient été réalisés dans le
domaine de la santé avec des en france
il ya eu 100 mille lits supprimer cent
mille idées hôpitaux supprimé en 20 ou
30 ans et je pense que effectivement si
ici les impôts importants que nous
payons en europe et est allé au système
de soins et au système éducatif c'est à
dire là où ils doivent aller en priorité
il n'aurait peut-être pas été nécessaire
d'arrêter toute la société au point on
l'a fait pendant aussi longtemps
donc ça pose plein de questions
notamment sur les systèmes de santé mais
pas seulement ça pose plein de questions
sur la manière dont on vit sur la
manière dont on produit sur la manière
dont on consomme donc c'est une crise
majeure et dont je pense pour l'instant
nous sortons abîmé et bt et pour
certains d'entre nous très en colère
donc que vont faire les institutions
pour répondre à ça et pour pour aller de
l'avant
je ne sais pas mais effectivement il
faut il faut des réponses fortes et et
des changements aussi la société madame
à hautala l'un des changements
ça va peut-être être sur le terrain
écologique le trafic aérien il a diminué
de 60% ce que vous appelez de vos voeux
en tant qu'écologiste est ce que le
corona vie aussi bien nous montre le
chemin pour nous déplacer mais en
polluant moins
je pense que c'était très important que
la commission européenne et toute
l'union européenne a déclaré la green
deal le green deal européenne et même
avant la crise qu vide
je pense que on est très conscient que
le retour normal si on peut parler à la
normale et ce sera différent comme en
navarre et les fractures notre société
sont exposés maintenant par la crise
qu'ovide et aussi la facture écologique
et on est aussi très conscients qu'il y
a liaison avec les pandémies aide par
exemple la biodiversité
il faut mieux respecter la nature et il
faut aussi créer une
modèle de société économique sociale qui
donne les réponses et à la crise
climatique et je suis convaincu que les
programmes européennes sont elles sont
en train d'intégrer la dimension
écologique est complètement et commet
députée verte je suis naturellement très
heureux de ça mais c'est pas clair que
les forces progressistes est bon gagner
ici parce qu'il y a toujours les
entreprises qui ne vont pas changer le
business model oui en même temps ce
virus il a lui finalement un effet greta
thoune bergues
finalement cet activiste écologiste
puissance 10 en quelque sorte
madame aguilar pour un parti
nationaliste comme le vôtre est ce que
c'est le moment de faire table rase de
d'en terminer avec l'économie d'avant
qui n'était pas soutenable trop
productiviste et d'aller vers une
décroissance une croissance plus
contrôlée est plus verte
c'est je je je crois est posé une
question on parle d'une révolution
desquels révolution par le nous parce
que moi je parle de la révolution du bon
sens pour moi c'est là signifie défendre
l'économie réelle et pas l'économie des
login pas l'économie verte et l'économie
de les stratégies de la pharma la table
que veulent nous imposer comme la seule
solution jeu par le cyclone yasi sans
rien changer
ce lien vous ont rien changé de main
coesys tu sais le monde d'avant doit
ressembler au monde le mont doré doit
ressembler au monde d'avant change rien
dans le logiciel on revient à la
croissance comme avant à manono mais
écoutez il met et écoutez si vous me
laissez répondre je meurs sic et il faut
parfaitement coexister la l'économie
d'avant l'économie est portée rieur
alors c'est aussi de défendre les fonds
des recrutements pour protéger ceux qui
perdent tout da tout dans cette crise
alors même à ma collègue il parle de
l'aider la biodiversité de l'économie
verte même et ça c'est très bien mais
pas
seulement il faut parler de ça il faut
en parler aussi de l'agriculture
confessionnal qu'elle peut coexister
parfaitement avec la culture écologique
coller une meilleure les européens ils
vont changer selon vous de la de
logiciels ils consomment localement ils
prennent conscience des aberrations
parfois de leur chaîne de production et
du commerce mondial c'est l'occasion en
effet pour les européens de vraiment
prendre conscience et de se saisir de
l'urgence climatique
c'est ce que c'est ce que je souhaite en
fait on est on est nombreux souhaitait
effectivement qui est qui et enfin la
prise en compte des enjeux de climat et
d'environnement
mais c'est disent que ce que je crains
c'est qu'il ya un effet de rattrapage
dans la consommation c'est à dire
effectivement les gens sur un petit peu
bloqués chez eux et un petit peu un
petit peu perplexe et que dès que les
choses s'ouvriront et qui aura moins de
2 de pression sanitaires les gens se
remettent à consommer comme avant et à
finalement se moquer complètement des
conséquences il ya aussi toutes les
toutes les manières de produire qu'il
faudrait changer toutes les des
incitations fortes donné à
l'environnement on a vu récemment en
france avec le président macron qu'un
certain nombre de propositions
écologique porté par les citoyens n'ont
pas été mises en oeuvre et sont pour
l'instant écartée donc en fait où il
faut agir vite dès maintenant puisqu'on
va sortir de ces crises donc c'est le
moment idéal pour pour changer les
choses mais j'ai un petit peu peur
qu'ils aient beaucoup de réticences
aussi bien de la part des consommateurs
que des systèmes de production qui sont
malheureusement organisés selon un
modèle
un modèle ancien où les externalités
comme on dit ne sont pas prises en
charge
alors madame hautala l'un des plus gros
bouleversements aussi de cette crise
sanitaire survient dans notre relation
au travail les petits métiers de
services d'alimentation ont été
revalorisées à l'occasion du confinement
tandis que le télétravail s'est imposé
pour des millions d'européens qui
travaille depuis chez eux
et maintenant quelle relation au travail
pour le premier point je voudrais dire
que malheureusement il n'y a pas eu des
possibilités de tout le travail de douze
de faire télé travail et c'est une
protection d'avoir cette possibilité de
télétravail mais les infirmières
des professionnels qui ont été faits des
tâches essentielles dans nos sociétés et
non pas cette possibilité
je pense que d'un côté le télétravail
est une possibilité c'est un privilège
mais c'est aussi quelque chose qui
produit les nouvelles problème
isolation et tout le monde a le
sentiment il n'y a pas de possibilité de
discuter avec l'autre mais je pensais
quand même que le traité le travail est
ici à rester après la crise parce que
peut-être ça offre un peu de
possibilités de faire meilleure balance
entre le travail et la vie privée
la famille est tous à s'aimer au
parlement européen m on discute ça aussi
comment est-ce qu'on peut travailler
dans une même manière flexible a créé la
crise madame aguilar vous souhaitez
également que le télétravail se perpétue
au delà de la crise sanitaire le risque
c'est pas un isolement accru pour les
télétravailleurs
bon d'abord je dirais que cette pandémie
affecte à tout le monde et et je crois
qu'il enverra les problèmes
psychologiques 1 dans un futur proche de
d'être avec la solitude et tout ça ça ça
avec le travail le thé le travail ça
passe il faut revenir à la normalité le
plus tôt possible l'être humain comme
vous savez a besoin de la compagnie des
autres et pour moi le télétravail ne
peut pas être une position et ne doit
pas être utilisé pour paris semble
réduire les salaires ou armes étaient
les temps de travail et moi je suis
d'accord qu'il faut faire une mix entre
le travail la famille les amis les le
tour a gelé les personnes ne doit pas
être celle je crois que ça c'est pour un
moment et le travail mais pas porte pour
toujours
alors justement corinne meilleur avec
bonjour paresse votre livre vous
conseiller
et de ne pas en faire trop a déjà à
l'époque il ya plus de dix ans
détruisant au passage le mythe du bon
soldat du monde de l'entreprise
aujourd'hui beaucoup prennent la
tangente pendant la pandémie des
étudiants privés de courant distance
ciel des salariés a cédé motivé il faut
dire beaucoup plaident pour un revenu
universel on en sera ou post pandémie de
la valeur travail
je joue moi je suis je suis très
sceptique concernant la valeur travail
enfin je vois même pas de quoi
exactement on parle moi il me semble que
ce que ce que la pandémie a mis en
lumière c'est c'est l'organisation
d'ensemble du monde où finalement les
petits métiers
entre nîmes est enfin les gens qui sont
en première ligne sont les plus
importants je crois enfin j'espère qu'il
y aura une remise en question de ce
modèle là c'est à dire cette espèce de
chasse bureaucratique sur toutes les
activités qui est sensé dans l'esprit de
certains organiser la compétition entre
les territoires les individus et des
activités puisque en fait le monde
marche comme ça en fait
avec donc cette chape de bureaucrates
qui parle un jargon invraisemblable qui
pour certains ne travaillent pas
beaucoup il faut quand même le dire est
qu'ils brassent du vent dans les bureaux
puisque c'est malheureusement comme ça
que ça marche et ce seront les mots de
la fin merci à toutes les trois d'avoir
participé à ce débat
merci à vous d'avoir été sur nos
antennes vous restez bien sûr sur france
24 et public sénat
pour plus d'informations
[Musique]
oh